ya que hemos hablado de los actores
principales en el sistema inmunitario
específico lo que vamos a hacer en este
vídeo es hacer un resumen para que el
ponen todas las piezas
entonces el primer linfocito del que
hemos hablado es la célula be o
linfocito ven lo que hace interesante a
esta célula bm es que cada una tiene sus
propios anticuerpos específicos unidos a
la membrana para cada célula ve los
anticuerpos unidos a su membrana
específica tienen una parte variable
entonces esta célula be tiene su parte
variable por aquí de esta forma y si
quisiera dibujar otra célula ve por acá
entonces la parte variable sería
ligeramente diferente por ello
diferentes células b responderán a
diferentes antígenos oa diferentes
patógenos que entran a nuestro cuerpo
ahora bien para que una célula se active
necesita pasar lo siguiente necesita
unirse a un patógeno en uno de estos
anticuerpos asociados a la membrana
vamos a escribirlo unirse a un patógeno
o mejor dicho a un antígeno ok pero eso
no es todo
a veces es todo lo que necesitamos pero
otras veces necesitamos que sea
estimulada por una célula t entonces voy
a escribir estimulación de una célula t
colaboradora si te preguntas cómo es que
una célula t colaboradora estimula a
esta célula bueno es que las células ven
son también células presentadoras de
antígeno es decir ingieren al virus lo
descomponen y lo presentan como un
complejo cmt2 así que vamos a dibujarlo
parte del virus se presenta en este
complejo
después la célula t colaboradora cuyo
receptor t es específico para esta
célula ve llega y la activa ahora una
vez que está activada se empieza a
diferenciar y al hacerlo empieza a
clonar se y puede transformarse ya sea
en una célula efecturá por cierto esto
es cierto para las células ven y las
células stem una vez que está activa
sigue clonando se y transformándose ya
sean las efectoras o células de memoria
las células de memoria se quedan mucho
más tiempo por lo que en el futuro
tendrás muchas más de estas versiones de
la célula ven y si de nuevo te infectas
con el mismo antígeno o patógeno en el
futuro entonces será mucho más probable
que se encuentre con este tipo de
células b y por lo tanto la respuesta
sea más rápida
por otra parte las células efectoras
básicamente se transforman en máquinas
de producción de anticuerpos entonces
dicen oye vamos a producir muchos de
estos anticuerpos que se pueden unir a
este antígeno que tenemos en el sistema
así que van a empezar a construir toda
una maquinaria celular y empezarán a
producir anticuerpos como locos y quiero
señalar una cosa que mi esposa me señaló
hace poco cuando me escucho realizando
el último vídeo ella es profesora de
hematología y parte de la hematología es
el sistema inmunitario así que en
definitiva tenemos que creerle ella es
una experta en el tema
en el vídeo pasado dije de una manera
muy vaga que cuando las células se
activan en el caso de ser células
efectoras entonces producen anticuerpos
y ahora quiero ser completamente claro
sólo las células efectoras producen
anticuerpos pero si alguien viene por la
cara
y te pregunta hoy en qué células en el
cuerpo producen anticuerpos y tú
respondes que las células efectoras no
estarías del todo mal pero no tendrías
la respuesta exacta para ser más
precisos debemos llamar las células
plasmáticas las células plasmáticas y
las células efectoras son la misma cosa
pero normalmente cuando te preguntan qué
le pasa a las células ve cuando producen
anticuerpos entonces se llaman células
plasmáticas es decir ya no las llamarán
células y quiero ser muy preciso en esto
ya que mi esposa dice que cuando algunos
de sus asistentes le preguntan sobre
cuál célula en el cuerpo produce
anticuerpos ella no puede contestar que
son las células ven o las células
efectoras ya que le dirán que está mal
pues la respuesta correcta es células
plasmáticas esta es la terminología
adecuada que se usa en los círculos de
inmunología
patología de hecho dije que ya se mató
lo ga no no no perdón en ella estudio
reumatología a veces me confundo entre
todas las logias que hay pero de
cualquier manera esto es lo que hacen
las células ven y estos anticuerpos que
producen pueden atacar y arruinar virus
y bacterias
es decir antígenos y los etiquetan para
que los recojan los macrófagos y otro
tipo de fagocitos bien estas fueron las
células
después tenemos a las células t y vamos
a hablar de las células t ligeramente
distinto de lo que hicimos en los vídeos
pasados para darles un nuevo matiz hay
dos tipos de células t y seguramente me
vas a decir de manera inmediata si las
células t colaboradoras y las células
citotóxicas y no estás mal sin embargo
esta vez voy a hacer una ligera
modificación para que también te
familiarices con estos términos
tenemos dos tipos de células stem todas
las células tienen receptores stem así
que vamos a dibujarlos
pero también tienen otras proteínas en
ellos algunas tienen estas proteínas
llamadas proteínas 74 mientras que las
otras células t tienen otra proteína
llamada said orc así que llamaremos a
una de ellas célula t cd8 positiva ya
que tiene la proteína cd8 y la otra la
llamaremos célula t cd4 positiva ya que
tiene la proteína 74 ya sé que no he
usado estos términos antes y seguramente
me dirás oye de dónde sale esta
terminología ahora el receptor cd4 es lo
que une a los complejos cm2 así que la
mayoría de las células t cd4 son células
t colaboradoras ojo estamos diciendo que
la mayoría de las veces y quiero ser muy
claro en el campo de la inmunología los
investigadores siguen descubriendo cosas
de manera regular las personas siguen
estudiando estas cosas
y hay todo tipo de casos especiales pero
normalmente cuando una persona habla de
células cd4 positivas está hablando de
células t colaboradoras que como ya
sabemos se denota como t con un
subíndice h de manera similar las
proteínas cd8 se unen al complejo ce m h
1 esto es lo que lleva a las células que
tienen cáncer y han expresado antígenos
en su complejo se m h 1 así que la
mayoría de las veces las células cd8
positivas son células citotóxicas que se
denotan como t con subíndice c
a menudo antes de que una célula se
active se les conoce como células cd4 y
cd8 pero después de activadas por
ejemplo las células cd8 cuando es
activada y empieza a matar cosas se le
conoce como citotóxica pero todo esto es
un juego de palabras espero que tengas
esta idea general bien ahora vamos a
recordar qué hacen estas células como
dijimos se une el complejo cnh 1 que
presenta un cierto antígeno en el vídeo
pasado aprendimos que cada célula
nucleada en el cuerpo expresa un
complejo cnh 1 este es el caso en que
algo absurdo está pasando dentro de la
célula tal vez un virus la infectó tal
vez es cancerosa y por lo tanto necesita
morir de otra forma seguirá produciendo
virus y si está infectada por un virus o
se seguirá dividiendo si es cancerosa
infectar al resto del cuerpo por lo
tanto las células cd8 mata
células malas ya que el cáncer no es
realmente una infección matan células
malas que en otro caso seguirán
produciendo virus o seguirán
dividiéndose y esparciendo el cáncer
mientras que las otras células se
sienten atraídas a las células
presentadoras de antígeno profesionales
y siempre dibujamos una célula
dendrítica ya que son las mejores
células presentadoras de antígeno y
ellas tienen complejos cm2 y debido a
que ingirieron alguna antígeno y lo
presentan justo aquí esto activará a las
células de colaboradoras y una vez que
todos ellos estén activados empezarán a
diferenciarse como células efectoras y
de memoria y la célula t colaboradora
efecto ahora hace un par de cosas
primero puede activar células b y
también puede liberar citocinas imagina
que activamos esta célula entonces
empieza a liberar químicos los
sirven como alarmas para avisar a las
otras células que se pongan en marcha
tal vez las células ven y las células
citotóxicas empiezan a proliferar de
manera más rigurosa de hecho parte de la
activación de la célula t citotóxica
puede ser asistida o puede tener un
estímulo por estas citoquinas es por
ello que estas son alarmas y por lo
tanto esta es el timbre de alarma
mientras que las células cd8 o las
células de citotóxicas en su modo
efector pueden matar otras células por
último tenemos el modo de memoria este
hará un montón de copias de esta célula
original y ellas estarán incluso más
listas de lo que originalmente estaba la
original así que si en el futuro algo
como esto o como esto ocurre entonces se
activarán más rápido porque se las van a
encontrar más rápido
espero que este resumen te haya servido
pese a que introdujimos un poco más de
terminología y una vez más quiero
mencionar el punto de mi esposa ya que
ella dijo oye no quieres que los alumnos
vayan diciendo que las células producen
anticuerpos incluso aunque pensemos que
sean células efectoras recordemos que
las células activadas se pueden
diferenciar en células efectoras pero
ahora ya sabemos que cuando entramos en
la escuela de medicina las personas
querrán escuchar células plasmáticas